walk him to this video playing again
against Andrew Martin I had him I played
him just check um a couple of weeks ago
like two weeks or something okay he's
playing um miss playing them the carers
system version of them the Bogle Indian
Wow cooing is seven here I've simply
forgetting at the moment what I'm
playing here I think I play for
really wow that's that's good where are
you going now to d4 no you just retreats
that's interesting
isn't this just a good position for
white I mean what exactly is black doing
here now I need that many many good
people good ways to play actually even
taking it Queen d2 is just good for wide
I wonder about Knight c3 actually queen
p 2 and yeah that's that's probably very
good for white isn't it now that's good
for what I don't believe it if it takes
if it does not take care you can you can
avoid to take but this looks um yeah
look looks like very strange chest let's
let's see Quincy to maybe um it's now I
mean this is really something that
should be refuted immediately Queen p3
is a good young it's also good let's
leave it clearer he cannot really take i
mean he can but it's well very very ugly
and dumb Queenie seven okay wow that's a
it's hard to believe
um night behalf he will move the kingdom
or what I even have beef before had
before and c5 coming yeah okay let's
let's move let's let it move the King
first night a 6 i'm going to take a
sixth of both so it it's it's a king's
now okay I'm so Bishop d3 or 92mm I
guess I'll 95 even my g5 what is he
doing against that rook fhm now okay I'm
going to do going to do this moose this
also came yeah but the center the point
is that it's not attacking anything I
can just play before and c5 p.m. it's a
pin this is why doubling on the B file
is not good
yeah should I go see five not so clear
now I should I should keep pieces on
that's just better okay 125 that's not
good I mean the position is is very very
nice but it took me a long while it to
to set this up
ok so now Kevin let's protect you three
chaplain come on can also add morning
can also easily play a g4 which I would
like to do
yeah so now he had to remove his rook
from the edge farm yeah 48 seconds
that's not good how to improve it's a
very nice position but it's not so
apparent how to make any headway
no this decide this is nice giving me
the c6 some point of entry okay maybe he
can play Nightsister no he doesn't i
will put something on c6 no matter what
he's doing that's that's almost a pre
move yeah now this is a disaster I get
the 935 the exchange is worth noting
here
check
note that that be success needs to
protect it all the time I can even go
here now how does he protect b6
check yeah these points are made for
walking b6 and so on now I guess he
resigned now nope okay let's win the
rook check check oh I belong to tell you
form in general I'm not so quickly i'm
jack is early morning games check back
for fits on time yeah yeah I'm just a
bit too slow in the morning and maybe I
should have thought a bit about it I
mean winning the rookies obviously
enough but it here this position is so
strong i can even avoid that and just
improve like bring the King to be five
something like that and go all the way
to be five and I'm going to win it just
it's just much easier but that look
let's look at this it was really a bit
of a weird opening um there are multiple
ways for a good position but I thought
that this should be it should be okay
because he has a hard time to take him I
thought rook see one
computer wants to play the immediate 9
p-5 which also is not not bad at all if
you look at this no that is this one
even it's not playable at all this means
he must play this check I guess check
then we have this position yeah that's
also quite nice for what okay this is
what you played and now over the
computer says merciless as usual a 3 is
much stronger even yeah that's that's a
direct refutation actually this is using
the Queen and he goes here this is d 6
and I b5 that'sthat's a flat-out win and
then and over here and t6 something like
that check it's just winning because if
I this is falling as well you're not
even going to develop the bishop okay
this was even stronger but ok this is
also very nice for wide here c5 was
interesting right okay I mean this is
not not bad it just keeps an advantage
it's it's how always stare tough to
determine the best possible way maybe I
should have done something else here
like H FOIA here for example h4 is much
stronger to prevent to prevent his age
for but I had to spend so much time
already for not much um that F that I
didn't didn't see that one so here yet
he had some counter breaking f2 was not
so better okay I lost I lost a few tempe
but it's still a very good position on
the queenside and b6 is so it's not
helping even night and even this
catch him to be honest looks looks
terrible and I've got this one also yeah
that's very good for also ok but this
keeps his rook looks at bay and this
this was surprising okay yeah yeah okay
this is just just normal this exchange
sacrifice it puts the pressure here and
what is what is blacks move I play look
see one next term he probably has to
take it and this is just an excellent
compensation he's always tied to the
beasts exponent I have numerous ideas to
improve like this or Bishop see form is
a very good position yeah okay this this
wins outright just well I could have
played 95 check as well but okay if you
get the b6 porn it's yet simply it's
simply sufficient yeah and here okay
this this is winning but I should have
maybe played it like I describe this is
much easier and did get the king over
all the way to be five or get the rook
involved so that you don't have any I
mean this is not technically difficult
but with 20 seconds he will continue
this forever and can I manage to plunder
away all the pawns check so this wasn't
jan wasn't really great but considering
how good the position was before i get
that so that's a fair result alright
thanks for watching